look i think that the reality is that uh
vladimir putin has already crossed the
red line into into barbarism and i think
it's now up to
nato to
uh consider
uh together the appalling crisis in in
ukraine the appalling suffering of the
people of ukraine
and to see what more we can do to help
the people of ukraine to to protect
themselves and see what more we can do
to
tighten the economic vice around the
putin regime and that's what we're going
to be we're going to some of the things
we're going to be talking about do you
believe that there could potentially be
a recession as a result of this invasion
of ukraine should europe and the rest of
the world be prepared for that i think
it's very important that we
work together to get this thing done as
uh as fast as possible the harder our uh
our sanctions the tougher our uh our
economic advice around the putin regime
the more we can do to help the
ukrainians i think the faster that uh
this thing can be over thank you all
very much